what's arthur harrow's actual plan and
why is steven grant being forced by
konshu to share his body with mercenary
mark spector keep watching for how
episode 2 of moon knight unravels the
mystery warning spoilers for episode 2
of moon night ahead
after steven grabs the scarab and flees
mark's storage container he once again
gets to experience conscious unhealthy
obsession with creepy hallways this one
at least ends in a fortunate fashion as
steven almost literally bumps into layla
the woman who'd been trying to reach
mark spector as it turns out she's
mark's wife and she's still angry about
his disappearing act this pretty much
confirms that layla is the mcu version
of marlene arauna though steve faces
some very understandable difficulties
when he tries to convince layla that he
and mark are separate personalities the
pair seems to warm up to each other from
the moment he notes that he wishes he
could remember their times together it's
clear that the former museum gift shop
worker has taken a liking to his
alternate personality's wife could moon
knight be setting up one of the
strangest love triangles imaginable
you're gonna get her killed you hear me
of course it's not like layla needs a
romance angle to be an interesting
character she's a skilled fighter and
extremely capable on the field
especially compared to her comic book
counterparts who's often stuck as the
damsel in distress conscious even
planning to turn her into its next
avatar a fate mark is trying to protect
her from konchu knows this and uses it
as a bargaining chip to get mark to do
its bidding
many fans were no doubt delighted to see
moon knight's slick mr knight persona
pop up in the marketing material the
character's stylish secondary super suit
finally turns up in this episode but
instead of being a separate personality
or an alternate costume for moon knight
proper mr knight is a custom version of
the moon knight armor that manifests
when steven uses it and assumes suit
means a business suit mr knight seems to
have the same super strength the moon
knight costume grants though its
signature weapons are two cali sticks
instead of moon blades and it lacks the
cape the comic book version of mr knight
is a more grounded affair than this
mystical version being little more than
a white suit and a full face mask that
the character wears when he doesn't need
to go full moon night it'll be
interesting to see where moon knight
plans to take this version of mr knight
if it shows up again besides no one can
say that the suit doesn't look good on
steven except for mark that is the
ceremonial armor from conscious temple
not psycho colonel sanders
arthur harrow continues to present
himself as a well-meaning spiritual
leader but his calm demeanor and lentil
soup do little to mask the sinister
undertones he constantly sprinkles into
the conversation especially because said
conversation starts with two of his
minions abducting poor stephen harrow is
more connected to stephen and mark's
predicament than anyone could have
thought the reason he's so familiar with
the voice steven is hearing is because
he too was once an avatar of konshu at
some point before mark took over harrow
left the moon god's service but remains
familiar enough with the deities ways to
accurately guess what it's saying i
am real justice
what's he saying now
i am real justice
since leaving kanshu behind harold's
methods have become far more extreme the
reason he serves ahmed is that he
believes the goddess can destroy evil
doers wholesale before they even commit
their crimes hero believes this method
will force people to be good because
they won't have the option to do evil
steven is not too happy about the deaths
this minority report approach would
cause particularly those of children
despite harrow's insistence that it
would create to paradise disturbing his
herald's plan is the reveal that he used
to be affiliated with konchu is arguably
even more momentous he specifically
mentions the fist of vengeance title
which implies that harrow has either don
the moon knight mantle or been a version
of another fist of consu type character
like hunter's moon perhaps it'll
eventually even dawn the cowl once more
should that happen the khanshu hating
villain could potentially battle moon
knight as a version of the corrupted
homicidal shadow knight
our heroes managed to win the cool fight
against the jackal monsters but their
victory does little to end their
troubles steven has discovered a whole
bunch of terrifying things mark has done
as konchu's avatar and is hesitant to
relinquish control to him when steven
finally does hand over control mark says
he intends to stay the dominant
personality until the amit situation is
over for his part mark's genuinely sorry
for his actions and explains that his
entire motivation is to pay his debt to
kanchu and my
servitude
is the price that i pay this might be
easier said than done though hiro opens
a whole can of worms when he invites
stephen to think about kanchu's
motivations to choose a man struggling
with mental health issues as his avatar
as well as whether the moon god could be
the cause of said issues he also
outright tells mark trust me when i tell
you
can't you
is a liar there's always one last thing
without question konchu acts as
unpleasantly as possible throwing
tantrums and lording over its avatar at
every turn for people who are familiar
with the source material this is a
pretty bad sign as is the moon god's
apparent refusal to let go of mark
konchu has spent a large portion of his
comic book appearances as something of
an antagonist who isn't above subjecting
its avatar to prolonged mental torture
sure the lunar deity might technically
fight the good fight right now but if
mark manages to defeat hero in egypt
what happens next check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about moon night are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you